green room has one of the most
intriguing plots of the year at least
this is one of those films where the
plot synopsis alone got me in the
theater this films about a band that
takes a gig at a neo-nazi bar that
already sounds like a horrible idea but
these characters aren't exactly the
smartest apples in the whole bunch we'll
just leave it at that after they witness
a crime being committed that could
implicate some of these people they get
trapped in a small green room and the
leader of these neo-nazi shows up played
by none other than the great Patrick
Stewart and from there on out a very
unnerving suspenseful grisly gory game
of cat-and-mouse starts and this is not
the type of suspense that makes you go
whew that was chilling and I feel really
cool because that scared me it's the
type of suspense that makes you go and
in this rare case I don't think that's a
bad thing this movie had to be that
disturbing and it's sometimes there are
moments where I actually just was like I
don't need to see that that's a little
much I'm not saying it's a bad thing it
sort of really sells the horrifying
situation these characters are in this
comes from the director of blue ruin
which is a film I enjoyed but was
particularly annoyed by how stupid some
of the characters were unfortunately the
director has chosen to make a very
similar film in regards to its
characters there really is no one to
root for you don't want this band to be
murdered but you don't really feel
particularly much for any of them
because they're all kind of dumb and
they do really stupid things and make
the worst choices you could possibly
make in a situation like this it's not
to say that all of us would do the smart
thing but sometimes when you're watching
these movies you just want to take these
characters and wring their necks and
tell them why in the living hell would
you ever do something that dumb you're
going to die and it's funny because the
director himself has actually
acknowledged this he calls this the
third film and his unofficial inept
protagonist trilogy this is another film
that he's made in which some characters
have absolutely no idea what they're
doing and are thrown into a horrible
situation and they make choices that
don't make sense and they suffer for it
and the director has acknowledged this
it was a little disappointing to see him
do something
similar in that way but this film is
different enough from blue ruin that I
can look past that I just hope his next
film is in another movie about a bunch
of idiots that get caught into a
horrible situation because I think that
would be pushing it what impressed me
most about this film was actually not so
much the performances it was the level
of suspense generated it is an unnerving
film from the end of the first act the
final shot I was on the edge and
sometimes it was unpleasantly unnerving
the things I saw in this movie for me
none of it was enjoyable to watch it is
a difficult film to watch but I can't
deny the fact that I was on edge the
director had me in his grip and a lie
that is due to a very good performance
from two people Antoine Yelchin and
Patrick Stewart these guys strangely
enough are both Star Trek characters uh
uh one is check off and the other is
jean-luc Picard and that's kind of funny
I just I just now thought of that what
was unfortunate though is that Patrick
Stewart never really gets that big
moment I feel like his character was
underutilized and has such a great actor
in such a strange role for him I do feel
they didn't get enough out of that
character looking back on the film there
isn't that one scene where I think oh my
god I'm gonna re-watch that scene
because he was so incredible in that
scene for instance the movie heat
directed by Michael Mann great film
filled with tons of amazing scenes but
what's the one scene that everyone
always focuses on as being the scene
well the dinner scene between Pacino and
De Niro there was never that one scene
for me in green room for his character
and I wish that he had that moment but
he was just sort of giving a good
performance all the way through but I
feel he was underutilized so as a
suspense film it works I was on the edge
of my seat for the majority of it
nevertheless I liked it good
performances good suspense they could
have utilized Stewart's character a
little bit more and I do wish the
characters that we were supposed to kind
of be rooting for were a little more
smart than they are and make decisions
that weren't like just straight-up 1980s
horror slasher decisions like one of
them literally goes we should split up
yeah that's a good idea let's split up
and I was just like did you really just
say that it's like the biggest horror
cliche of all time and some of these
decisions they make don't make any sense
nevertheless green room had me in its
grip for the majority the runtime and
I'm going to give it a B
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I'm going to have some more
reviews coming for you very soon this
weekend I've already seen some other
films going to be reviewing those
shortly you guys are the best thank you
so much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes